donc il y a quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas auquel je ne suis pas
censé pas de maintenant je me rends
compte que je comprends pas bien les
données symbolique si vous voulez c'est
comme ça et donc je suis
extraordinairement surprise l'ampleur
qu'a pris cette chose est immédiatement
c'est d'ailleurs dès que mon premier
papier a été envoyée la chasseuse de
têtes l'a fait dire que j'avais des
conflits d'intérêts avec sanofi ce qui
est complètement idiot je fais des
essais thérapeutiques pour personne ça
fait 25 ans que je suis contre je fais
pas la deuxième chose est la demande
elle a fait de confirmer elle nous a
fait faire envoyer au journal qui
menaçaient de l'enlever cet article qui
est devenu le plus cité de toute la
littérature soit la thérapeutique vous
convient de 19,7 cité et 2400 fois en
dix ans que je n'avais pas eu les
autorisations ge a pas eu de cdp et la
troisième chose déluge des gens qui sont
des maniaques de méthodologie je ne
pouvais pas imaginer qu'en envoyant un
papier comme ça comme j'en ai envoyé
tellement dans ma vie si vous voulez
ceux ci allaient faire une espèce de
folie mondiale et donc toutes les
explications qu'on pourra donner sont
pas inintéressantes s'est enquis triera
pour comprendre ce qui se passe moi
personnellement je ne comprends pas ça
ne fait pas partie de ce que je suis
capable de comprendre parce que il me
manque une case sur la signification
symbolique des choses peut-être pas que
symbolique
en tout cas c'est pas mon c'est un
problème donc nous on a continué à faire
je pensais depuis longtemps
en réalité depuis plus de vingt ans je
pensais qu'il fallait faire comme pour
les centres anticancéreux des centres de
lutte pour les maladies infectieuses qui
comprenait tous les patients le
laboratoire la recherche
petit à petit je l'écris a 20 ans quand
j'étais le conseiller de de mattei et de
madame haigneré où j'ai rencontré
d'ailleurs gilles bloch donc qu'ils
connaissent et parfaitement mes projets
puisqu'il n'est dans au cabinet de
maintenant et directeur it there il
était entré au cabinet de mme à
l'améliorer en dix ans pour faire face à
des situations comme celle-là il faut
avoir des structures organisées dans
lequel on fasse tout dentelle y ait des
gens qui soient compétents à tous les
nobel et à tous les niveaux de manière à
pouvoir répondre
toutes les questions au fur à mesure et
pas avoir un ordre dispersé donc l'
ordre dispersé sur le sénateur je savais
qu'il allait arriver
c'est pas moi qui les disperser nous
étions en ordre dispersé et d'une
manière très singulière donc pour pas
que vous croyez que je considère qu'à
paris plus rien n'est organisé c'est pas
vrai en neurologie si quelqu'un avait un
problème dans ma famille je l'enverrai
la pitié parce qu'il ya un centre de
neurologie qui est colossal
s'il y avait quelqu'un qui est un
problème génétique que je l'enverrai
sûrement un écart et imagine pas de
problème avec ça mais en maladies
infectieuses
ici on a détruit l'organisation des
maladies infectieuses
elle n'existe plus et donc si vous
retrouvez avec un pauvre marseille est
en train de vous dire ce qu'ils pensent
c'est parce qu'il ya une destruction
physique de l'organisation des maladies
infectieuses qui était à l'hôpital
claude bernard là les forces de maladies
infectieuses l'institut de veille
sanitaire a été mis à saint maurice
alors que c'était une vraie bonne idée
moi j'avais écrit à l'époque de le
mettre à côté de pasteur ou de maître -
des antennes de pasteur à côté voyez le
les hôpitaux de maladies spécialisé en
maladies infectieuses ont été dispersées
dans toute la ville et donc vous n'avez
pas de cendres vous n'avez pas de
pardonnez moi je vieillis vous n'avez
pas de patron et si de maladies
infectieuses voulait pas